[موسيقى]
يختار بعض سكان سراييفو قمه هذا الجبل
المسمى القلعه الصفراء المطله على المدينه
لتناول وجبه افطارها من رمضانيه تتجمع
العائلات قبل ساعه من موعد الافطار حول
مدفع رمضان الاطفال ينتظرون على احر من
الجمر مشاهده اطلاق المدفع والصائمون
يحضرون موعدهم السفريه لتناول افطارهم
[موسيقى]
اطلق مدفع الافطار واذن لصلاه المغرب في
سراييفو والجميع يتوجه الان الى طاولته
المؤقته او يختار ركنا يطل على المدينه في
ساعات الغروب لتناول وجباتهم وقضاء بعض
الوقت في هذا المكان الذي يعج بقاصديه
ليلا في شهر رمضان المبارك ليث مزاريفو
البوسطه والهرسك لمتابعه المزيد من
الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على يوتيوب الضغط على
زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات